hey everybody we are
live on youtube i'm dave rubin and in
honor of passover and easter we're going
to be discussing how to find
freedom peace and hopefully some hope in
our challenging times
joining me today are the senior rabbi of
sinai temple right here in los angeles
rabbi david walpy
and the founder of word on fire
ministries in santa barbara california
bishop robert barron gentlemen welcome
back to the reuben report
thank you dave thanks for having me i
feel like you guys are my two
official clergymen you are the clergy of
the reuben report so i'm thrilled to do
uh this show with you today and we're
going to try to keep it as apolitical as
possible and just talk about
spirituality meaning
purpose hope all of that good stuff but
i'm going to start i'm going to put you
guys both on the spot right now and
rabbi since we're in the middle of
passover i'm going to start with you
because we've already had the seders
today is good friday obviously sunday is
easter
what is the main meaning that you would
want your congregants or anyone watching
this to
to hear and to know about passover right
now
i think the main meaning of passover
is the multiple levels of freedom
that the holiday teaches there
is obviously a political level that
people should be free
which is one of the reasons why passover
was for the pilgrims
such a powerful holiday because they
wanted to found a free country
there's also internal freedom there are
people who are enslaved inside
themselves to all sorts of things uh and
then there is the freedom of knowing
ultimately
that there's something greater than
ourselves which doesn't relieve us of
the responsibility
of doing things in this world but lets
us know that there are limitations
to human talent and genius and there is
something greater
so i think all those levels of freedom
and our responsibility
to ourselves to the world and ultimately
to god
is what is the core of the passover
teaching
bishop same question to you this time
easter
jesus christ has risen from the dead and
therefore
god's love is greater than anything
that's in the world so on the cross
jesus
takes on all of human dysfunction if you
look at those passion narratives and the
gospels you know you've got stupidity
and you've got arrogance and injustice
and cruelty and violence and
all of it comes upon him he goes under
the darkness of the world but then
through the power of the resurrection
the god of israel shows himself to be
more powerful than anything that's in
the world and therefore it's a message
indeed of
liberation of new life of hope
so i'd say that i put the focus on on
the facticity of the resurrection
but then we can draw all kinds of
implications from that and i really love
what the rabbi said about about freedom
i think is absolutely right
freedom from to be sure freedom from
forms of oppression
uh but always in the bible it's freedom
for as well
and ultimately freedom for the worship
of the true god
i love in the passover account uh in the
exodus account
when moses says to pharaoh you let my
people go
okay that they might worship me in the
desert
and so it's freedom from oppression but
then freedom for
the worship of the true god i can say
more about it later but the very fact
that the cross and resurrection is
central to
catholic worship so the mass which
represents the cross of jesus
is our greatest act of worship freedom
from
all the powers of the world freedom for
the worship of the true god that's
easter i think so as i said i don't want
to go too political but obviously the
word
freedom the word freedom of its in and
of itself right now seems particularly
political
how how much uh feedback are you guys
getting
from your congregants about how they are
worried about the state of freedom at
the moment bishop i'll go to you first
well the congregants are always
interested in these political matters
and you do hear from
all parts of the of the spectrum to be
sure
but what i would stress is
this fundamental spiritual freedom
that is more important than political
freedom political freedom is a function
of
this more basic spiritual freedom you
know
we read it in fact at mass last night we
had the account of the passover
and all the familiar elements of you
know put the blood on the lintel and the
angel will pass over
and the firstborn of the egyptians both
man and beast will be destroyed but then
there's a little line
that says and i will execute judgment
upon the gods of egypt
and i think that in some ways is the key
the pharaoh was a political figure if
you want but in the ancient world they
didn't make those distinctions that we
do between
religion and politics he was altogether
a religious figure
and so god is passing judgment not just
on the political oppression of the
pharaoh
but upon the false gods of egypt
and it's the worship of the true god
that he wants to make possible you know
the same is true today there's all kinds
of false gods
that are at large in the land you know
today we'd worship
wealth and power and privilege and honor
in our own our own sovereign selves
those are all the false gods now of
america or of the west
that god passes judgment upon and so
it's freedom from
oppression freedom for the worship of
the true god i think that's always the
central
issue rabbi did you sense that people
this year at the seders that it
it felt more relevant or something i
mean that's what i felt at
this year it had it had a particular
meaning this year you know
i would say first of all um i i entirely
identify with what the bishop said
absolutely uh about
false gods i think by the way that the
um
the principle false god is the worship
of
politics as religion um and and
and a truly religious devotion that
people have to their political stance
such that they have equal faith in it
with the faith that believers are
intended to have in religion and that is
uh
that's a social ill that's not a good
thing um
and then the other part of it yes is
misrayam actually in hebrew
which is the hebrew word for egypt comes
from the word meaning narrow
and we've all been in a very narrow
place we've been home
we've been locked in and this idea now
that we are being freed
um and the pace of freedom or the
slowness of freedom
is i think something that people feel
very very deeply
and the other element of this is that
the passover was the time that
israel became a people not just a family
not just a clan but a people
and the opportunity the bishop and i
were talking about this
right before we began the show to
worship together again to be a people
is i think something that we desperately
uh need in fact i really believe this is
maybe presumptuous i think we need it
more than we realize we need it
because i don't know what your
experience has been but when i see
people in person i'm almost
startled at my own joy um
it's like an actual person so it's time
yeah well let's continue down that path
because i'm i'm amazed by that too i
mean
i did a little meet up with with some of
the members of the reuben report
community a few weeks ago in la and and
i kid you not
people were literally crying saying
hello to other people
just to be out the tears of joy
obviously
but that missing that where well i don't
i actually don't know what you both are
doing in terms of live congregants right
now so
actually bishop what are you doing right
now and i know santa barbara has
probably
i'm guessing slightly more lacks rules
than here in los angeles
it did for a time now it's it's actually
worse than la but that's another
issue but last night for the i had the
biggest crowd i've had since covet
started last night i was up in santa
maria to parish
john neumann and it was for the first
time in a long time there were a lot of
people
in the church and then many outside the
church and i agree
with the rabbi it was it was thrilling i
mean it's thrilling to be in that
again after this long hiatus but you
know let me go back to the
the exodus account again because i the
figure of moses to me is so important
you know for both the
passover and for for easter because
moses is a liberator i mean we all know
that and and he's played this
very important role up and down the
centuries very much in our country you
know
people identifying with moses the
liberator but of course a little bit
later
in exodus moses is the law giver
and those two ideas are not mutually
exclusive you know we tend to think that
way that
if i'm free i'm freed from all these you
know laws and rules and regulations
but no israel receives through the
liberator now a whole set of laws
many of which are not what we call moral
laws but liturgical laws
so he's teaching israel how to give god
right praise not because god needs it
god needs nothing but
he's training a people in right
worship see that's why i think the fact
that a lot of the churches have not been
worshiping publicly we've not been as
present in the society
that's bad for the society because i
think the job of the churches in many
ways
is to teach a society write praise
so we don't privatize religion but but
the liturgy is a is a public act
and it's bad for society if liturgy is
um
is suppressed so i think that's an
important moment right now as we come
back
all of us come back to worship god that
has huge societal implications
um i i want to piggyback two two
comments on that the first is
we do have an inclination to slavery
inside ourselves
that is there are people who feel safe
inside and are afraid to go outside
because freedom i mean eric from wrote a
book years ago escaped from freedom and
there's a phrase in the bible that god
delivered the
israelites with a mighty hand and then
outstretched arm and a rabbi in the 18th
century said
you don't need both the mighty hand
though is what brought them back
out and the outstretched arm was to keep
them from going back
because the israelites wanted to go back
to slavery was safe it was slavery but
it was safe
um and and that's a preference for order
over freedom
and as the bishop says uh certainly in
the jewish tradition
law is a prerequisite for being free you
can't be free without laws if everybody
drives and no one observes traffic laws
there's no freedom
there's an impossibility of getting from
one place to the other
and so every society seeks its balance
um america has always tried to err on
the side of freedom
but it is a constant struggle both
within our lives and
and within our society do you guys think
that all of this that we're discussing
right now in relation to covet and
lockdowns and freedom and everything
else
presents a truly unique opportunity that
maybe
for for guys like you that are heads of
congregations
uh to to bring new people into the fold
because i really sense and i think you
guys
know from talking to me i mean i'm more
of a believer now than i've ever been in
my
adult life for sure and one of the
things that i found in the last year
is that most of the people who are
making sense to me
are believers because they're they're
believing in something outside of the
the day-to-day okay i turned on cnn here
we go uh and i wonder if you
you sort of relish in that opportunity i
suspect you probably do
bishop well i've been beating this drum
for a long time both here in la but also
nationally is to say we can't just
presume
oh the people all come charging back
when we open the doors
catholics have now had a year of
practice of staying away from church
which is
really bad now you know we did it for
good reasons and all that but
i've been saying we've got to be very
proactive in drawing our people back
and i've been saying to those who are
coming to mass now you got to be
evangelizers when the day comes i want
you to bring
two or three people back to mass who've
been away for a while
so yes it is i think a great opportunity
as i mentioned too it's of huge
importance for the wider
society the churches can't retreat into
privacy i think
especially now we should um
be a public force in the society but
yeah it's a moment it's an opportunity
rabbi jews don't evangelize as well as
catholics so what do you do
um we well we evangelize to jews
right and and to and two i think what is
properly called the unchurched
um but it is i i think that it is
both uh a moment of peril and a moment
of possibility
that is a lot of people have discovered
oh i can sit at home and and watch the
services you know with a cup of coffee
and in my pajamas um and have been
comfortable with that and will take some
luring to get back especially
if they're scared but having said that
i really do believe exactly what you
said dave which is that
never has a religious message at least
in my lifetime
been as compelling and as important as
now because
people realize that a pandemic
is a spiritual crisis it's not just a
public health crisis
it's a spiritual price and and the
things that people are coming to me with
their you know the first thing that the
bible calls not good
is aloneness it is not good for a person
to be alone
everything is called good until you get
aloneness
and that's what the pandemic there's
been a plague
of isolation and people feel it not just
as an emotional
or as a mental health issue but as a
genuine spiritual issue
and people who have deep spiritual lives
i venture to say feel the aloneness less
than those who feel like they're alone
in the universe
and that seems to be the ultimate irony
of what we've done to ourselves we're
social creatures
and they told us basically to be to be
anti-social bishop
what else are you doing on that front uh
maybe that's not directly related to
what you're doing
in the church but just to help people
sort of reconnect
at the moment well one thing i did at
the beginning of covet is i told people
look see this as an opportunity maybe to
read that great spiritual book that
you've been putting off for years you've
got more time and and more
space to do it um reach out to people
in need so during the covet period all
sorts of folks they were in need of
basic sustenance and supplies and so on
reach out by
zoom or by phone call to those who are
lonely so i said take advantage of the
opportunities we have during you know
covet but then the parishes too we're
trying to find all sorts of ways to
re-engage the kids to re-engage
the older folks to have pilgrimages and
public you know
processions and activities um so we're
trying we're hopeful that in a few
months maybe if the vaccinations
continue we can do it
but we're trying to be proactive and and
um just engage people
you know i we we can't succumb to this
privatization or we can't just you know
throw up our hands i think we've got to
be active
proactive yeah rabbi what about you
so the same i mean we've had drop bys
and and
our school has been running now and the
school is now in person which is a great
thing
um and uh and we're starting in person
services this
we've had them outside now we're going
to have them inside this saturday but
again
it's got to be you know it's limited to
um it's actually not this happened next
saturday sorry um
it's limited to 25 then there's social
distancing and we're hoping
um eventually to have those rules
relaxed and have people
yeah you were gonna i see i see a
question on your lipstick well
yeah i'm curious to do either one of you
can you look
to a specific verse or or
parable from the bible about fear in
general because i think what a lot of
people
it really is just going to be the the
fear thing to get over to literally just
walk into those doors again whether the
door is a temple
a church or a school i will tell you
that the most common thing in the torah
that god says
is in hebrew it's al-tira in english
it's
do not be afraid that actually
the single indispensable quality to lead
a good life is courage
without courage you're a slave when the
israelites left
egypt they stood at the sea say the
rabbis and it wasn't until one man
jumped into the sea that the sea parted
because god wanted them to take a risk
it's like i'm not gonna part to see
unless you actually do something
and the same thing here i understand
that there are risks in the world but
there are always
risks in the world and all of us know
you can't do anything you can't achieve
you can't fall in love you can't have a
child
you can't make a friend anything unless
you're willing
to take a risk emotionally physically
and so
um i think that the the culture of risk
aversion has gone too far
i understand why people are risk averse
i mean you know i bury people who've had
covet and it's real
nonetheless um life
is in part about you know jumping into
the sea
yeah the theme of fear you're right is
central to the bible and the new
testament in some ways culminates with
the claim that perfect love
casts out all fear it doesn't say
perfect love casts out all hate
so the opposite of love is fear i think
of paul tillich the
german-american theologian last century
who said
fear is the fundamental problem it's not
so much pride tillich thought but fear
because i'm afraid i cling to myself
because i'm afraid
i set up you know barriers because i'm
afraid i lash out at my enemies etc
perfect love casts out all fear well
what do we see in the cross but the
perfect love of god
which took upon itself all of the
darkness of the world
which is why the risen jesus in all the
accounts always does
two basic things is he shows his wounds
it's a very important move i think
uh don't forget what you did don't
forget what the world has done the
wounds of jesus are our own
sins the sin of the world there it is
but then he says shalom so there's that
word that
i think in many ways sums up the whole
the biblical revelation the peace
that god has always wanted his people to
have but it comes on the far side of
fear
it comes on the far side of a fear that
he's conquered
through his dying and is rising there's
if you want the easter message that that
conquers the fear that bedevils us
this south african author um uh
alan payton has a beautiful scene in one
of his novels not crime
the beloved kind of but another novel
about a guy who goes to heaven
and he comes before god and god says
where are your wounds yeah
and he says i don't have any wounds and
god says why was there nothing worth
fighting for
yeah that's good yeah so actually that's
a perfect segue to where i want to go
which was just a little
something maybe more personal to both of
you but in this past year as you've had
to you still had to bury people and do
services and
then most things were on zoom and and
all sorts of that i just wonder just on
a personal note
how what kind of toll this took for you
guys and did it challenge any of the
beliefs that
you talk about and that you live your
life or uh rabbi
it i would say it was it was certainly
the hardest year that i've had
as a rabbi and every clergy that i've
spoken to
has said basically the same um and
uh and i've had other years that were
very difficult in lots of ways um but
the first of all the incoming volume
of sadness and isolation was tremendous
and the
inability to respond i mean i have to
say
not to i never thought that not being
able to visit people in the hospital
would be such a burden
but it was a real burden to say to
people that i've now known for
20 some years i can't come see you
you know in the hospital i can't be with
your mother in her last moments
you know can you put the phone up to her
ear for god's sakes which is
which is not the way any of us it's not
why we do this
we can go into this business you know to
make phone calls when people are dying
um and so that part was very difficult
but
but the part it didn't challenge my
faith because
i saw that even that was still
so powerful and people would say look i
know you couldn't be here but the fact
that you called or
the fact that people showed up on zoom
for the memorial service
meant so much that it reminds us
um that that they're just there is
nothing more
powerful than presence however that
presence is configured
bishop yeah it's a good question i'm
sort of
you know amusing about it um in some
ways
personally in some ways it was a good
year in the measure that it kind of
slowed me down and a lot of the travel
that i was doing i couldn't do any more
i was at home much more often i finished
a book
i've been and i was on the back burner i
finished this book during the covid year
i did have more time for prayer so i do
a holy hour in the morning and it became
sometimes a holy
hour and a half so there were some
things that were good about it that it
kind of stopped me in my track slowed me
down
i totally agree with what the rabbi said
there about
pastorally it was a real difficult year
and how important
touch is you sort of forget that that
actually touching people being
in touch with people how important that
is pastorally and we couldn't do that um
and also the hospital thing i felt that
for sure
in the worst part of copenhagen when
people were dying of covid and
some of our priests if they put the
hazmat suit on and all that they could
come in like
space men to visit people but that was
devastating to families
and we did the same thing as like just a
phone maybe just by phone you could
speak some words of
comfort that was really hard personally
so it's kind of a mixed bag in a way and
i try to encourage people
to see a positive element to quieting
down
slowing down having more time with
family etc so maybe that was
a grace of this year but pastorally it
was it was hard
absolutely yeah yeah so since i said i
was going to try to keep us away from
from politics but as you said rabbi
everything sort of
sort of you know brings us back to
politics in a weird way
i'm curious without going into anything
specifically political
unless you want to um are you talking to
other clergy members
about how when things really open up and
people start coming back
how you're going to deal with things
like sermons where people are going to
expect you
basically to do politics at this point
because
of all of the things that we're talking
about here
like like basically where do you guys
get your guidance from
i try very hard to avoid it's not always
avoidable
i tried very hard to avoid it um and
and to have the kinds of conversations
that we've been having here
because one of the things that i'm
always aware of is
i don't know more about politics than my
congregants do
it's not like i have some special you
know pipeline to political wisdom
and so i'm sort of investing my
political opinions with illegitimate
authority
if i get up there and say you know this
is what
you should believe and so i really try
to avoid it and also
honestly they get enough of it in the
rest of the world but the rest of the
world as you point out
doesn't offer spiritual comfort and
doesn't offer guidance and won't tell
them what passover is about
and won't say what easter represents so
that's my job
yeah i agree it would be irresponsible
me to get up in a pulpit and say you
know here's the political party you
should vote for
the candidate we articulate principles
so catholic social teaching has all
kinds of
general principles and we're meant to
talk about those but i'll tell you a
story right before the election
i wrote a little piece 800 word piece
where i laid that out i said look i'm
not going to recommend a candidate i'm
just going to say here are some basic
principles
at the beginning of the article i said
i'm sure i'll offend everybody
which indeed i did so i wrote that piece
and i was flooded
left and right all yelling at me why
aren't you telling people
to vote for biden or vote for trump um
so that's the way we tend to do it in
the catholic context is we articulate
general principles
and then let people decide because i
agree with the rabbi too i don't claim
expertise
as a you know expert in fiscal policy or
foreign policy
i've got my private opinions but as a
bishop my job is to lay out the
principles so we keep doing that
i don't do this here's what i did not
this last election but the election
before and i repeated it again
in in miniature before this last
election i used john roll's idea
what's called original position i said
you're about to be born in america
you don't know who you'll be you could
be gifted not gifted you could be white
black
you know you have no idea you could be a
man you could be a woman anything
now vote for the candidate who's going
to create the society you want to live
in
if you don't know who you're going to be
and the idea of that is
don't only vote for the candidate who
will serve your self-interest
but who's going to be better for the
collective and when you've made that
decision
i think that you've chosen the candidate
that you should vote for
and of course people will come on
different sides of that decision
i don't really think that that
necessarily pushes you right or left but
it does
broaden people's thinking about what's
good for the society
all right i pushed us i pushed us into
politics let me let me
bishop do you want to add something
quickly no i'm just going to say dave
we've talked about com boxes and how you
know crazy people can be there
covid made them all crazier i think
that's true my experience
in the comm box world everyone got
crazier during covet everyone got more
extreme
so i hope maybe that will calm down as
we come out of it
yeah i'm curious do you guys think
there's also an interesting opportunity
for more interfaith dialogue or even how
do you think
that's particularly important right now
i mean i know you guys we we've done
this before on my show and i know you've
appeared other places together and do
these sorts of events but i do
sense that as i said before the people
that are making sense to me
they're talking about things like
judeo-christian values
and that is something that obviously
brings two people of different faiths
like you guys together
uh bishop we should make common cause
i've been saying that for years now in
ecumenical dialogue with other
christians is you know we can fight
about the 16th century till the cows
come home
or we can make common cause against a
rising culture
that is you know the culture of
self-definition the culture of
self-creation values are simply a
function of my
you know private whim well the great
religious traditions i mean grounded
in our case in the bible stand to thwart
that and
and we ought to speak because as as our
friend jordan peterson often points out
a society gets sick if it loses contact
with these great articulations of value
and religions do that you know so we
can't just retreat into privacy as i say
but we should make common cause i think
oh i would say certainly all biblical
people should make common cause
and speak to a culture that really needs
what we have to say
so let me give you an example that i
think fits very beautifully into what
the bishop was talking about last night
on thursday nights i do a torah class on
clubhouse
and this one was about passover and love
and someone was saying
that for a lot of their designing ais
to respond artificial intelligence to
respond to men
when they send messages in to women on
the internet
and and this idea of
drawing people away from actual human
interaction
and contact to idealized
screen interactions um
this is like the antithesis of
everything
that judeo-christian values speaks about
the antithesis of it because
we believe in in the friction of real
human interaction
and of face-to-faceness and so i think
that yes the things that we believe
are so enormously important in our
culture
that we have to join together to
represent them
yeah well you know between obviously
today good friday
easter sunday we're in the midst of
passover i know you both are
extremely busy so i'm gonna just uh give
you one more question
on on the hope thing that we've sort of
been bouncing around for about a half
hour now
about can you just give one last message
of
of hope to people uh from your
perspective and and from a religious
perspective and
and from maybe even a secular
perspective uh bishop you first
god's love is more powerful than
anything that's in the world and that's
the ground for hope
not a ground for naive optimism but a
real ground for hope
and so relying on the world whether
that's politics or economics or whatever
culture that's not going to do it but
relying upon god
whose love is greater than anything
that's in the world that's the ground
for hope
so the more we awaken a sense of god
among our people
the more hope there will be that's what
the easter message is i think
and i i want to i want to both affirm
and also
give one direction to that which is that
that
the passover message is is that as well
but it is that
god's we are god's hands in this world
that every human being is an image of
god and the hope comes not only from the
presence of god but from our ability to
use that presence to be godly in this
world
and that redemption in this world to the
extent that it will come before an
ultimate redemption
will come through human effort and
decency and goodness
and kindness and that those qualities
exist in abundance even though um
we have to work somewhat to reawaken
them in our day
well gentlemen i thank you for your time
happy passover
happy easter we're going to let you go
i'm going to finish up with some words
that are going to be far
less interesting than what you guys have
offered up but thank you guys and
and thank you so much and always a great
pleasure yeah and i hope we can do this
in person soon enough right i love it
all right thanks to rabbi david wolpe
and bishop robert baron
and i hope that was just the right way
to send you guys
off on the weekend uh if you're
celebrating
uh happy good friday to you and and
happy easter
i know we've done the the seders already
but passover is winding down
and uh yeah in case you couldn't tell i
needed to get a little away
from like the political madness i was on
twitter this morning and it was just
like
one we had this show booked already of
course but it was just like one
crazy thing after another the cdc saying
one thing
five minutes ago and another thing the
next day and passports
for vaccines and don't go outside and i
saw that
the president or the prime minister of
england saying vaccinated people can't
even be indoors together like just such
craziness like such
sort of secularism on steroids craziness
and i think we did a little something
there for a half hour that hopefully
gave you a little bit of peace
and as i've been saying a lot lately you
know we can all just sit here
and just look at the world horizontally
but maybe if you look up
every now and again that was probably
the most religious thing i've ever done
if you look up every now and again maybe
there's something there
anyway have a great weekend everybody
and uh i will be off
the machines but if you want to say hi
and share some food pictures and wine
and music and that kind of stuff
reubenreport.reubenreport.locals.com
have a great weekend and i'll see you
monday